une première mondiale qui soulève de
nombreuses questions éthiques et de
santé une italienne de 35 ans attend des
jumeaux après l'implantation dans son
utérus de deux ovules appartenant à deux
femmes différentes
quand la science joue les apprentis
sorciers valérie gage et gilles marini
est elle et son petit frère guillaume
sont deux faux jumeaux nés après
fécondation in vitro
rien de plus normal quand on sait que
cette technique favorise les naissances
multiples mais le cas qui vient d'être
révélée dans cette clinique italienne
est unique
ici deux couples ont eu recours à la
fécondation in vitro
le médecin a donc obtenu deux embryons
génétiquement différents ces deux
embryons ont ensuite été réimplanté dans
l'utérus d'une troisième femme une mère
porteuse
après son accouchement prévu en
septembre les deux bébés seront séparés
pour être remis à leurs parents
respectifs
le gynécologue qui a pratiqué
l'intervention n'y vois aucun
inconvénient
là nous avons affaire à deux bébés qui
vivent dans deux sacs différents de
placenta différents et sont nés de deux
nouveaux sites et de deux spermatozoïdes
différents donc qu'il ne souffriront pas
d'être séparés on peut imaginer qu'il y
a dans l'utérus de la mère des relations
qui se passe entre les deux enfants et
dont on sait pas du tout comment l on
devenir ou ce que ça va entraîner pour
l'enfant une fois que la séparation se
fera après la naissance en france la loi
sur la bioéthique de 94 interdit la
pratique des mères porteuses
l'italie pourrait bientôt suivre le même
chemin après plusieurs grossesse
atypique le ministre de la santé vient
de réclamer une réglementation urgente
et une réflexion éthique sur le sujet